terrorism is very scary especially when
it happens close to home and not in some
faraway place nobody likes to be afraid
and we were eager to make the fear go
away
so we demanded more security in the last
decade it's become increasingly normal
for civil liberties to be eroded and for
government agencies to spy on citizens
to collect and store their personal
information regardless of whether you're
a fan of right or left wing policies
this affects every one of us so we have
to take a look at the data and ask
ourselves honestly has all of this
actually made us safer
[Music]
in the aftermath of 9/11 the US
government concluded that the law had
not kept pace with technology it created
the terrorist surveillance program
initially to intercept communications
linked to al-qaeda officials were
confident that if the program had been
in place before 9/11 the hijackers could
have been stopped but soon the new
powers were also used to prove guilt by
association the FBI used immigration
records to identify paracord was ylim
foreign nationals in the US on this
basis 80,000 individuals were required
to register another 8,000 were called in
for FBI interviews and more than 5,000
locked up in preventive detention not
one terrorist was found in what's been
called the most aggressive national
campaign of ethnic profiling since World
War two how commonplace it's since
become for government agencies to
collect and store the personal data of
citizens was made plain by the leak of
the Snowden documents in 2013 they
showed how the NSA can demand
information about users from firms like
Microsoft or Google in addition to their
daily collection of data from civilian
internet traffic such as email content
and contact lists so instead of focusing
on criminals governments are
increasingly turning their attention to
everyone but if you're looking for a
needle in a haystack adding more hay to
the stack isn't going to make it any
easier to find the needle on the
contrary every recent success announced
by the NSA has come from classic target
surveillance despite high hopes the NSA
surveillance program has not stopped any
major terror attack for instance one of
the Boston Marathon bombers was already
a target of the FBI so what we need is
not even more random data but better
ways to understand and use the
information we have spy agencies are
also pushing to [ __ ] encryption in
early 2016 the FBI asked Apple to
produce a backdoor program to disable
the encryption of a terrorists iPhone
Apple publicly declined not only because
this tool could be used to permanently
weaken the privacy of law-abiding
citizens worldwide but fearing to open
the floodgates for governments
requesting access to a technology
by billions of people a fair shared by
security experts and cryptographers a
few weeks later the FBI revealed that
they had hacked the phone themselves
basically admitting that they lied to
the public about the need for a backdoor
which questions how trustworthy spy
agencies are in the debate about privacy
and security especially considering that
the NSA for example already has the
capability to turn on your iPhone
microphone or activate your laptop
camera without you noticing concerns
about this are often met with the
argument if you have nothing to hide
you have nothing to fear but this
reasoning only creates a climate of
oppression wanting to keep certain parts
of your life private
doesn't mean you're doing anything wrong
right now we live in a democracy but
imagine the damage the wrong person
could do with all our data and such easy
access to our devices anti-terrorism
laws allow the authorities to
investigate and punish non
terrorism-related crimes more
aggressively if you give law enforcement
powerful tools they will use them that's
white democratic oversight is so
important even if those tools and laws
aren't used against you today they might
be tomorrow for example following the
November 2015 Paris attacks France
expanded its already extensive
anti-terrorism laws by giving law
enforcement greater powers to conduct
house raids and place people under house
arrest
within weeks evidence emerged that these
powers were being used for unintended
purposes such as quashing climate change
protests the governments of Spain
Hungary and Poland have introduced more
restrictive laws on the freedom of
assembly and speech freedom of
expression and the press in Turkey has
been seriously undermined in the last
few years with people sentenced to
prison for criticizing the government
none of this is effectively helping us
fight terrorism the motivation behind
this might be good even noble but if we
let our elected governments limit our
personal freedom the terrorists are
winning what's worse
if we're not careful we might slowly
move towards a surveillance state
the data is pretty clear the erosion of
Rights along with mass surveillance
hasn't led to significant successes so
far but it has changed the nature of our
society terrorism is a complicated
problem without simple solutions no
security apparatus can prevent a few
guys from building a bomb in their
basement we should keep the principle of
proportionality in mind creating master
keys to enter millions of phones is not
the same as searching a single house in
most countries the law already permits a
wide range of actions including targeted
surveillance to take full advantage of
this existing potential we need better
international cooperation and more
effective security and foreign policies
better application of our present laws
instead of new and stricter ones that
undermine our freedom
let us not out of fear destroy what we
are most proud of democracy and our
fundamental rights and liberties this
video was made possible by your support
on patreon.com and the european
liberties platform live at his dot EU
you